[Music]
so why are we talking about managing
payments today well a lot of apps
require you to be able to exchange money
you know and especially because that's
probably the primary way that you are
making profit off of an app it would be
nice if we could just do it out of the
goodness of our hearts but it is
important to be able to break even or
make a profit so a lot of different
applications require that ability so for
instance mobile commerce apps there are
all sorts of stores seem to have their
own applications right now and there's a
rich on-demand economy you know you can
get anything delivered to your door
within 24 hours or ride-sharing etc and
there's also software as a service like
subscription for billing software cloud
services etc we are most focused on
these first two bullets because if
you're familiar with how apps work in
the App Store when it comes to goods
that are digital that is managed
differently so in this case we're
talking about tangible goods
specifically we're talking about a
hypothetical online flower store that
Susan and I are going to open and it is
going to be called mobile florist and
Susan's gonna tell you a little bit more
about our app thanks Anne yeah so we
built out we've been building all this
great flower application I'm very
excited about it the way that this will
work it's a four-step process like many
things in our talk today and you'll
order flowers via the app so figure out
which flowers you want and select them
and then step two will be scheduling a
delivery so when will our person come
and deliver these flowers to you then
the third step is making a payment via
the app so actually using your credit
card to charge the customer
that'll be most of what we talk about
during this talk and then step four will
be getting your flowers delivered so how
do you actually get the services so
that's how we'll build out the business
model and with that in mind I'll go into
talking a little bit about how we'll be
building the application so
there's four steps to this process and
we'll do an authentication process so
how does a user log in and access their
information how do we create them in
firebase how do we schedule things so
store their information and then finally
how are we going to manage those
customer payments and then we'll follow
up with how might we handle a refund in
the application so just a little bit
more of a use case for refunds so we
know that managing payments can be kind
of intimidating you this is the part
where you actually charge your customers
and so if you do it wrong you can do it
really wrong and no one wants that it or
road's user trust so we're gonna talk
about how you can handle payments in a
way that's safe and seamless for your
customers and we'll use two technologies
stripe and firebase so I'm gonna talk a
little bit about why we're using strike
first I'll explain what stripe is in
case it's we don't know it's a payment
processor and so that means that it
handles charging the credit cards and
this can be really helpful because we
don't want to be in the business of
handling credit card information in our
app we kind of want to focus on flower
delivery because that's what we care
about and so we want to take the process
of actually making payments and handling
credit card information all of the
security concerns like what if someone
is trying to use an old card how do we
handle that and stripe and other payment
processors do a really good job at this
so for us it makes the most sense to use
a payment processor to handle that type
of information and security and
convenience so we're gonna use stripe
here but you definitely don't have to
use stripe we really only picked it
because we know the stripe API and we're
familiar with it but you can use any
payment processor that you want so
that's why we're gonna use stripe and
I'll pass it off to John to explain a
little bit about why we're using
firebase thank you so there are actually
several reasons that we're going to be
using firebase because we are using
different products along different steps
so I'm gonna break it down by each step
that we're taking here are the firebase
technologies that we're going to be
using today firebase authentication
cloud fire store and cloud functions for
firebase going back to our four steps
yes
is going to come up quite a bit our
first step is going to be authentication
in order for us to know who is going to
be paying where we're sending the
flowers storing that information so when
the user comes back to the application
they still have all that we need a way
to verify who our users are but we know
that auth is very complex though it is
essential if you've ever rolled your own
auth you already know this one option
that people use a lot is federated
identity providers like Google or
Facebook or Twitter and these are really
great options they definitely eliminate
some of the difficult work of setting up
ooofff
but at the same time there's still some
challenges so for instance what if your
customers don't want to use that account
to sign into your app or they just don't
have one or if you want to give them
more than one option how are you gonna
make sure that a user who signs in with
Google and a user who signs in with
Facebook still have the same type of
user the same type of information so
another problem is what if someone
accidentally logs in with one provider
one day and another the next how are you
gonna handle those situations
fortunately there's firebase off so
firebase auth supports all these methods
of authentication and more so email and
password Google Facebook Twitter github
anonymous which is very useful so for
instance when a user first goes into our
application it's not the best experience
- right out of the box make them need to
sign in they are invested yet and that
can really ruin the experience
so allowing them to explore the app and
then log in once they're ready to
schedule can give you a much better
experience at the same time you still
want to protect your information with
security rules and be able to identify
who your users are anonymous auth allows
you to do that when a user first comes
into the app you can log them in
anomalous anonymously and then every
time they return to the application it
is still the same user with the same
user ID and even better when it's time
for that user then to schedule something
and they choose the way that they're
going to log in
actually links automatically that
anonymous user with the email and
password or federated identity provider
that they sign in with so at least for a
very seamless experience and if you're
interested in a UI that looks a little
like this and you'll actually see
another example of it further in the
talk this is kind of an example of
firebase UI which is an open-source
project on github that allows you to
build some UI out-of-the-box for
different firebase products including us
and it really is as easy to add a
provider as it is to add a single line
of code and I know that it gets thrown
around a lot but in this case it really
is that simple so yeah that's why we're
using firebase off for our
authentication um our next step is going
to be scheduling and we need to store
that scheduling information somewhere so
that our customers can see their
scheduling information we need to be
able to see all of it so we can figure
out where to send the flowers so in this
case we are going to use cloud fire
store to store all of our data so cloud
fire store is a database in the cloud
that is built as part of the firebase
service it is divided into documents so
if you are familiar with a no sequel
model maybe you've used the real time
database before this is similar but has
some benefits so a document has inside
of it key value pairs that we're calling
fields keys are strings and values can
be all sorts of different things
strings numbers binary values they could
be boolean's and even these sort of
object a looking things so you have all
sorts of things that you can put inside
of a document documents are stored in
collections which are of course
collections of documents and these
documents can point to other collections
of documents you cannot have a document
inside of a document but you can have a
sub collection so what you end up with
is a structure somewhere
like this so what is the advantage of
storing your data like this as opposed
to just a full JSON blob like you might
get in the real time database what this
allows you to do is make shallow queries
for one thing so let's say I just want
the information that's in that
highlighted box it in a no sequel model
sometimes if you want to query that
you're gonna get all of the information
underneath it so you really have to
design your database structure such that
you keep it as shallow as possible and
that means that it doesn't necessarily
match with your application this allows
you to make a data model that really
mirrors your application and makes it a
lot easier to understand so on the
backend cloud firestore supports
security rules so along with firebase
off they can help you make sure that
users only access the data that you want
them to access so this is where often
cloud firestore work nicely together
since we can identify our users by their
user ID we can make sure that securely
they can only check their own data and
we are able to look at any scheduling
data so the final technology we want to
talk about is in terms of managing
customer payments and this is the bulk
of what you're going to see us working
on today we are going to use cloud
functions for firebase which are
event-driven meaning they react to
events that happen in your app this
could be when a user first signs in the
firebase auth or writes to a particular
document and cloud firestore writes to a
field in the real-time database maybe
triggers a conversion analytics event in
Google Analytics there are all sorts of
things that can trigger this you can
even have an HTTP triggered function so
that you can trigger it whatever you
want to then whatever these events occur
the cloud function starts to run and
whatever code that you have put in it
whatever actions you want to occur are
going to happen cloud functions are
written in typescript or JavaScript on
top of node.js which means you have
options the option to incorporate all
sorts of NPM packages looking at three
fifty thousand different packages at
your disposal so you could definitely
customize it this is not just for Google
products you can incorporate all the
different api's that you need which
we'll see today in terms of using the
stripe API so cloud functions work
inside a privileged Google environment
which means that unlike the client code
they aren't going to be subject to
security rules this is really beneficial
for when you want to make actions that
you don't want to be accessible to the
client you can send things here and do
checks before writing to places in the
database for instance that you wouldn't
want your client to be able to do so and
if you are run if you are using any sort
of Google cloud services usually set up
is a snap and you don't even necessarily
need to include some of those
configuration steps that you're used to
setting up so now that you know about
why we're using these technologies let's
dig into the good stuff the payments
cool so we are gonna do another
four-step process to manage our customer
payments the first step in there is
creating a stripe customer so we know
through firebase off that we have a
customer but we need to let stripe know
because that way we can actually do
things like add cards and also charge
payments and make refunds so that's step
one step two is then creating a payment
method so sometimes we say payment
method sometimes we say add a card and
sometimes we say source it's just a way
of paying for the service so we'll do
that and then next we make the payment
so processing the credit card then
finally we'll handle the refund so let's
go into the first step of creating a
stripe customer the way that this will
work is the user will log in and create
a firebase off user from there we'll go
ahead and trigger a cloud function based
on the creation of that user then we'll
talk to the stripe SDK and wait for the
data to come back in the cloud function
then with the data back we'll write that
to claude firestore so that we can use
it later let's look at what this is
gonna look like in code so let me walk
through some of this
a lot of code on the screen so here we
have a function called create stripe
customer the function is triggered off
of an auth so you can see functions auth
user and then on create so that means
that when a user is created we'll run
this function then we get the user
object here so that contains information
that were you use like the email address
or other things that we might need so
what we do is just talk to the stripe
API here so stripe duck customer is not
created so we're saying hey stripe make
a customer here's their email address
super easy and then we just wait for
that data to come back and we use a wait
here because it's typescript JavaScript
and if we don't use a wait it'll just
fall right through and we won't get the
data back so we have to wait and we wait
for the customer and then with that
customer we store it back to cloud
firestorm so we do that by saying admin
that fire store collection and then we
have a collection called stripe
customers and that collection is made up
of all of our users with the user UID so
we'll see in fire store this collection
and then a bunch of documents and each
of those documents will have data that's
related to their stripe ID and then
we'll also add other information there
so let's look at what this will look
like in our actual application so here
you can see we go and click the login
button and this will pop up some really
nice UI from firebase and this is all
part of authentication so we'll go into
you at the actual Google account to
login we pick our login account that we
want to use and we can see here we've
logged in successfully if we look at our
data viewer the stripe customer is added
there and when we click into it we have
the customer ID that we got back from
stripe well so pass it have to done to
talk about how we're going to create a
stripe payment method so now that we
have a stripe customer associated with a
firebase user we want to be able to add
a method for them to pay for our
services this involves the client stripe
SDK creating what is called a token a
token is a single-use payment method so
you give
a credit card or some other source of
information to the stripe client SDK and
they give you back this token that they
identify as the credit card so it
doesn't actually have specific
information about the credit card in it
which is nice because then we can write
it to cloud firestore without actually
storing any of that very sensitive data
at every point in this you will see that
we don't store anything that is
identifiable in terms of you know
someone being able to take the credit
card information from a user so we want
to store stuff that you know even if it
leaked wouldn't have much of an impact
so in this case we're just going to
write that one-time token which is
naturally going to trigger a cloud
function this at this point we're going
to speak to the stripe server SDK and
take that token and our customer ID and
link them together which gives us what's
called a source a source and a token are
very similar but a source is something
that you can use over and over because
we think that once someone orders
flowers through mobile florist they're
definitely going to want to do so again
finally we're going to write information
about the source into cloud fire store
which enables the client to be able to
see that the card was added successfully
and also see some information about
their card so here's what that cloud
function looks like in code our function
is called add payment source and in
terms of its form we have functions
again dot firebase all right that fire
store instead of in the previous case
you saw off here we have a document
which is stripe customers user ID tokens
auto ID this is where that token is
being written you'll see that a couple
of these fields are in brackets which
means that they are wildcard so whatever
happens to be in that place I will still
trigger this function it doesn't need to
actually say user ID in this case it's
actually going to be the firebase users
UID this is an on write function which
means it is triggered whenever there is
a write to that specific location so
that could be when it is first created
when it
change is made when something is deleted
all of that is going to trigger this
function which could be beneficial and
works for this particular situation but
you'll see that there are some cases
where you don't want that so to get the
data from firestore we're going to call
changed after dot data and this is going
to give us what was just changed in
cloud firestore if there's no data
because it was just a delete we're just
going to return out of this function we
don't need to proceed otherwise we're
gonna get the token from that data and
then we are going to get the stripe
customer ID from cloud firestore so this
is what we stored in the first function
that you saw and this is going to come
up a lot where we're going to need to
get that customer ID based on the
firebase user so we're just gonna put
that in its own function you'll see get
customer ID and that means we're going
to get the customer ID for this
particular customer which enables us to
do something like this
call stripe dye customers create source
pass the customer and the token and then
we're gonna write that information back
to the database notice we also have
something the instead of just a random
ID for the document we're using
something called response in the
response we have fingerprint which is a
unique identifier of that source and
that actually just makes it easy to
query this later we also call merge true
so that rather than overriding all the
information in a document it just merges
the fields together so let's see what
this looks like in action
here you'll see adding a credit card
feel free to try to use this it's just a
stripe test card it's really not gonna
do anything
also it's expired so it's really not
gonna good luck so the card has been
saved you'll see it says success and
after a moment the UI updates to show
the new card so here I could show a
little information about it and then in
cloud fire store you can see the kind of
information that comes back a lot of
these are null but if you wanted to
provide that information as well you
could okay so we have our stripe
customer we have their payment method
all queued up let's move on to actually
making a payment because that's the part
I'm excited about is make it some money
Sam Sam
cool so the way that this will work is a
client will write to cloud fire store
the charge that they're gonna make so
that'll come from the app and we'll see
that in our video later but we'll write
to quantifier store then after that will
trigger a cloud function so hopefully
this is starting to sound a little
familiar
then our cloud function will talk to the
stripe SDK and we'll wait for that data
to come back then with that information
we'll return the result to cloud
Firestar so before I go into the code
for this I want to talk a little bit
about cloud functions for a firebase
retries so cloud functions for firebase
are guaranteed to run at least once but
that means that they could run more than
once and we need our function to be able
to support that this is really important
when you're making payments because if
you run a function that charges a
customer more than once it could charge
them more than once which would be very
bad and users would be writing and they
wouldn't be using our app so we really
want to make sure that we handle this
correctly so the way that we're gonna
handle this it's called idempotency it's
a concept that if you run something more
than once with the same arguments you'll
only get one of the side of the only one
side effect of it will run so in this
case we're gonna talk to the stripe API
and if the cloud function
tries the stripe API knows with our item
potency key that we only want to charge
one time so we give them the same item
potency key and they won't retry
recharge the customer every time so
we'll see this in the code a little bit
later but just wanted to set the stage
for that so let's look at the code this
function is called create stripe
customer so it's run off of functions at
fire store document and that's when this
is created so whenever a document is
created in this location so we're in the
collection strike customers we have our
user IDs so whatever user we're in and
then we have a sub collection charges
and then the charge will get an auto ID
that is randomly generated but unique by
firestorm and we get the snap in context
so we can get information from that as
well
so first thing that we do is get the
customer ID since we need that to talk
to stripe will use our get customer ID
function here and pass in the contact
stop params that user ID next we get the
amount that were they're being charged
so snap data amount will have that
information and then we create a charged
object which is just the amount and the
currency and the customer next we need
to set the source so what credit card
are they going to be using do they want
to use a default card are they using one
that they have put in for the first time
maybe this is a corporate count for some
reason and they have a different credit
card so after that we need to get our
item potency key so what are we going to
use for that here well it needs to be
unique and it needs to be not changing
even though if we run this more than
once so a good example here would be the
auto ID of our document so even if this
function runs more than once the auto ID
won't change so it makes a really good
item potency key and so we'll just grab
that from the context up France then
we'll talk to stripe and pass in our
charge that we created earlier with our
currency and amount and customer and
also give it the item potency key then
we wait for that data to come back and
then store it in caught fire store
you'll notice here that we wrap this in
a
try-catch and that's because this logic
is really important and we want to make
sure any errors are surface to the user
so we have a function that says user
facing message and then we put the error
in there so the user can understand
what's going on with their application
so let's look at what this will look
like in our application now I'd also
just like to note very briefly that
there is the risk of the client pressing
the button more than once maybe they're
just really eager to pay you and
resolving that is actually a lot easier
than dealing with idempotency which is
the button in this case is no longer
active until a response comes back from
cloud functions so here we write through
the flowers are four click pay payment
was successful we can see wait for that
data and come back and we see the charge
to pass here we go and look into our
charges we can see all of this
information back from stripe here so we
have able to successfully charged our
credit card from stripe and we get all
this information back that can be
helpful Sam now I'll pass it off to Jen
to talk a little bit about handling
refunds because sometimes flowers aren't
always the freshest right so we would
like to think that we will never have to
refund our customers because their
product is just that great but quite
frankly it is going to come up from time
to time so in our case we want to set up
a system where users can request a
refund if they think that one is
deserved but we want to be able to have
the final say and what we are actually
going to refund to people because there
are certainly cases where a refund would
be a good idea maybe they ended up with
black roses instead of red roses but
there are some cases where you know it's
really not on us so if they send flowers
to someone but that person doesn't
actually want them so we want to be able
to pick and choose which refunds we want
to approve so in order to see how we're
going to pick and choose that let's look
at how we are going to prove refunds
starting to look familiar the client is
going to write a refund request to cloud
fire store which is going to end up in a
queue that we can see if we decide that
it
is a reasonable request we will approve
that refund this approval is going to
trigger a cloud function which is
actually going to do the refunding so we
need a way to distinguish between
moderators which right now is just us
but as our company grows there could be
more of them and regular customers so
that users can't just approve their own
refunds the way that we're going to do
that is through a concept called custom
claims in firebase off when you sign in
a user gives you a whole lot of
different information including the user
ID their email what providers they've
signed in with maybe an image URL which
could have come from their provider or
it could be provided by them and then
used to you know they can upload one and
then you can update the user there's all
sorts of information that's in there
there's also this little bit of
information on there off token which are
custom claims and those these can be any
kind of key value pairs that you want
but do note that they have a very low
limited size I think it's like a
thousand bytes maybe it's really not
meant for those cases where you're like
hey you'd be great if I could put in
their whole home address into the user
or the list of their friends it's just
four little pieces of information that
can distinguish one kind of user from
another so in this case we're gonna add
to our token a claim called moderator
and we're gonna set it to true so this
is how we're gonna see does this claim
exist on a user then they have to write
the right to make changes such as giving
refunds this also enables us to make a
different UI where we can see more
information this allows us to
distinguish between us being able to see
every scheduled delivery and clients
just being able to see their deliveries
so how do we make sure that only
authorized folks can actually become
moderators we don't want someone to just
be able to say I'm a moderator you know
give me that claim so
what we're going to do is make it so
that only existing moderators can give
that privilege in this case you could
get more hierarchical if you want maybe
you could have an owner property and
only that person gets to grant
privileges to other people for
simplicity's sake we are just checking
for a single claim but remember that you
can do sort of a combination of them so
this is what the function looks like to
give that permission we are using an
HTTP function but this one is a little
different it is an on call function
which means this call can only be made
from a firebase client you know your
Android app or your iOS app rather than
just being able to you know make it from
anywhere in this case passes data in
context we check the context because it
also passes information about the user
who has made the request we check their
OP token and see if they are already a
moderator if they are not we let them
know that they don't have permission to
make this change this for my format
might look a little strange if you're
used to doing a HTTP calls but this is
just how it's done so you can return
your fields instead of doing like a
response dot send if they are moderator
we're going to get the email of the user
that they want to promote so in this
case if I'm a moderator and I want to
promote someone else I want to promote
Susan I would pass her email if there's
no email I'm just gonna let them know
just keeping all my checks in there then
we have a function called get user by
email which enables us to get all the
information about these are based on
just their email if they're doesn't
happen to be a user with that email
maybe Susan has it signed up yet again
we're just gonna have another check
otherwise we're gonna get the users UID
which is what is required to add these
claims so then we set custom user claims
using their user ID and then passing
whatever claims we want in this case
we're just doing moderator true you
could do several claims that once if you
want you can do them over
I'm and they'll still all be there and
then we're gonna return a response that
the user is a moderator so this is how
we're making sure that only we can
approve moderators and only people with
the moderator claim are going to be able
to make refunds so once a moderator
approves the refund it's still going to
need to be processed by stripe so
Susan's going to show you how to do that
awesome cool so we have this refund
request that the user is written into
and I just wanted to give you all a
little insight into what this might look
like so we have the amount the approved
at which is what our moderator would say
yes or no to an ID closed at all this
type of information I'm just trying to
add more dates to these so that we can
have an insight if something goes wrong
with the customer to look back and be
like oh it was closed at this time like
it was approved at this time so this is
just a little insight into how we're
structuring some of our data so let's go
back to our example of how the approvals
been process for refunds get processed
so we write to cloud fire store to
request the approval and then a
moderator will come in and approve it or
not then that moderator coming in to
approve will trigger a cloud function
and then our cloud function will talk to
at the stripe SDK and then we will write
that data back to cloud fire store after
that so that's kind of the process and
so now we have our moderators so we have
a way to create moderators and we need
to look at the code to actually talk to
us right so let's look at that here we
have a function called refund charge and
so this is based off of function that
fire store document so refund request
and then on the ID and you can see this
is an on update function so this will
run when there's an update and we'll get
the change in the context here too for
this function so the first thing that we
want to do is make sure that the user is
a moderator and if they're not a
moderator we want to just return an
error and I've included an attempted out
here to be like hey someone tried to
refund this and
weren't a moderator so maybe pay
attention to that if you're looking
through it after that we want to do a
little bit more error checking here too
so we get our refund that we're trying
to issue and then we also want to get a
refund object before so we get our
refund that we're trying to issue by
saying changed after data so that would
be the data after the change has been
applied and we can get the data before
the change has been applied by saying
change before data so we want to make
sure two things here one that the refund
hasn't already been approved and two
that the previous refund hasn't been
approved so we want to make sure you're
not trying to re refund something that's
already been approved and then the
second one is that there is an approval
on it so make sure that it actually gets
approved by someone if either of those
are fall through so if no one if it's
already been approved or if no one
approved it also set an attempted at and
return so don't process this refund so
now with all of that error checking
aside we're gonna go ahead and talk to
stripe to process the refund so we call
stripe dot refunds not create with our
charge and the refund ID and we wait for
that data to come back here the response
can succeed and so if it's succeeded
we'll say great refunded at this time
and return that back and we'll let the
user now but if the refund doesn't
succeed we also need to make sure that
we set that data as well so we'll say it
was attempted at this time and send the
data back to the customer and to the
moderator so they can look through it
finally we've wrapped all of this in a
try-catch so just in case there was an
error talking to stripe for some reason
that wasn't a successful response or an
unsuccessful response we also want to
keep track of that so we'll say hey you
attempted this at this time and here's
like it didn't work and then report the
error so we keep track of all of that in
order to just help understand the
process for this refunds and understand
where our users are in the process so
let's look at this in our application so
here we have our list of approvals over
there and we can see approved at so it
was approved by our moderator and then
this all has the data about when it was
refunded the response that we got back
stuff like that so you can see that
process of going through and approving
things so the next step - we just
covered a bunch of data protection or
these like if cases stuff like that we
also want to make sure on top of our
moderator that we want to protect this
data and so as we mentioned earlier
cloud firestore has rules when it's
talking with a client to keep things
secure
so let's write some rules specifically
for refunds that can cover some of our
security concerns so if you're not
familiar with rules this a match basis
statement so here we have at the top our
databases and the database and the
documents that we're trying to match and
then each path in the database gets kind
of we can give it its own rule so this
particular statement is for the refund
request collection and the refund ID
there is a wild-card so it matches to
any of the refund IDs that you pass in
so these are all order together and so
you'll have more complex rules as you
build out your virus or database but
this is just as I said the refund
request once
so what we're allowing here is allow
read and create so if the user is logged
in and they're the one trying to create
the refund and they're not including
approve that so approve that is not in
the request out resource that data they
can read and create so they can't
approve themselves so this rule prevents
that then the next rule allow read and
write is so that moderators so you can
actually ask access that custom claim
token here
so if request off token that moderator
is true sorry that was a lot of words
but if that's true you can read and
write so that allows our moderators to
go in and update the request so with
that I'll pass it off to Jen to talk a
little bit about
our fifth topic yeah so the first time
we were going to deliver this talk we
actually had a twenty five minute window
so I'm super excited that we have a
little more room because we're able to
cover some topics that I think are very
important and exciting and in this case
we're gonna be talking about web hooks
so most payment processors are going to
offer you some kind of web hook and
ability to run trigger an endpoint when
something happens within the payment
processor so in terms of stripe this
could be pretty much anything this could
be when a payment goes through when a
payment is declined when a refund
happens when a new customer is created
when a new card is created they have a
whole list of things that you can
trigger endpoints from so again expired
credit cards failed charges and stuff so
in terms of making sure that it's just
not some malicious person triggering in
that end point stripe offers you a
signature header that you can use to
verify that this webhook actually came
from stripe and not somewhere else so
let's take a look at one example of an
endpoint in this case we want to do this
whatever whenever a customer makes an
update to their charge so in this case
if it seems to be approved upfront but
then later it actually fails we want to
be able to keep data in sync in cloud
fire store to reflect that change so
this is a regular HTTP request as
opposed to the ones that are only called
from a firebase client app so we're
gonna get the data this is provided by
stripe they're gonna tell some
information about what has happened
we're also gonna get the customer ID
because that's provided by stripe and
then we're gonna get an ID which is the
ID of the charge where that change
happened
now we're going to get the firebase user
associated with the stripe customer ID
so you've seen an example
of where we start with a firebase user
and then we get the straight customer by
looking in the cloud fighter store we
can do the reverse as well so in this
case we're gonna do it using a query of
fire store stripe customers where the
customer ID field of that document is
equal to the customer ID field that just
came to us from stripe and this does
return on the rate of documents even if
you said limit to one so in this case I
get the first document which is going to
be our firebase user who has that
customer ID and then we're going to get
the reference to that path to their
customer path similarly we want to know
which of their charge does something
happen to so now that we know which user
it is we can go into their charges and
get the specific document where the ID
of the charge is equal to the ID that
was just provided from stripe um now we
are going to add the information that
changed in that charge to cloud fire
store so in this case in that path I set
all of the data that just came from
stripe and again merged true so we have
the previous information about the
charge and then N and the updates like
the fact that maybe it just failed we
also send a response back to stripe
because they are expecting to know that
something was successful so you can
imagine that this could be very useful
you could have a specific endpoint for
all sorts of events that happen so today
we talked to you about a whole lot we
threw a whole lot at you at once
including how to create a stripe
customer and link it to a firebase user
how to store information about straight
payment method in cloud fire store
without storing the specific information
that makes that card identifiable how to
pay for things by writing the cloud fire
store and handling the payments from the
stripe server API now certainly you can
pay from the client but the benefit of
doing it this way is that you are then a
lot you know it makes it much easier to
function and update cloud fire store
[Music]